Hey there, Shankar here with some exciting news. Our live Perceptions Tour is returning the summer in partnership with public radio stations around the country. This time, we're heading to Northampton, Massachusetts, Burlington, Vermont, Boulder, Colorado, Grand Rapids, Michigan, Blacksburg, Virginia, San Luis Obispo, California, and Oklahoma City, Oklahoma. More information is at hiddenbrain.org slash tour.
大家好，我是尚卡尔，有个好消息要告诉大家。我们的现场节目“感知之旅”（Perceptions Tour）今年夏天将再次启程，与全国各地的公共广播电台合作。这一次，我们将前往马萨诸塞州北安普顿、佛蒙特州伯灵顿、科罗拉多州博尔德、密歇根州大急流城、弗吉尼亚州布莱克斯堡、加利福尼亚州圣路易斯奥比斯波以及俄克拉荷马州的俄克拉荷马城。更多信息请访问 hiddenbrain.org/tour。
I hope to see you at one of our upcoming stops. Okay, here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. Think about a time you flipped through an old family album. Maybe you paused on a photo of your grandparents as young adults. Their clothes look outdated. Their expressions, too formal. Perhaps you imagine what it was like to live in that time and found it impossible.
希望能在我们即将到访的城市见到大家。好了，今天的节目开始了。这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回想一下你翻看旧家庭相册的时候。也许你在祖父母年轻时的照片前停了下来。他们的衣服看起来过时了，表情也太严肃了。或许你曾想象过生活在那个时代是什么样子，并觉得那是不可能的。
Or think of a film set in medieval times. You may have thought, wow, these people lived in a completely different universe. I have so little in common with them. It's easy to believe the past is sealed off from us, that those lives, those cultures, those ways of thinking, have vanished from the world. But is that true? In ways we don't even notice, the choices, beliefs, and habits of people who lived long before us continue to shape how we see the world today. They influence what we value, the kinds of societies we live in, even how we relate to what we live, another. This week on Hidden Brain, and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, how culture and
或者想想一部以中世纪为背景的电影。你可能想过，哇，这些人生活在一个完全不同的宇宙里。我和他们几乎没有什么共同点。人们很容易认为过去与我们隔绝，那些生活、文化和思维方式已经从世界上消失了。但这是真的吗？在一些我们甚至没有注意到的方面，很久以前生活的人们的选择、信仰和习惯，仍在塑造着我们今天看待世界的方式。它们影响着我们的价值观、我们所处的社会类型，甚至我们彼此相处的方式。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，以及《隐藏的大脑 Plus》中的配套故事，将探讨文化和
history shaped the way we think. When you woke up this morning, you turned off your alarm and brushed your teeth. You had a bite to eat, said goodbye to your spouse, and commuted to work. You clocked in for the day. All of this seems so routine, so commonplace, that we don't stop to think about it. We don't realize how the patterns of our lives are shaped by the long ago and the far away. As the novelist William Faulkner once said, The past is never dead. It's not even past. At Harvard University,
历史是如何塑造我们的思维方式的。今天早上你醒来时，关掉了闹钟，刷了牙。你吃了点东西，和配偶道别，然后通勤去上班。你打卡开始了一天的工作。这一切看起来如此常规，如此司空见惯，以至于我们从不去思考它。我们没有意识到，我们生活的模式是如何被遥远的过去和遥远的地方所塑造的。正如小说家威廉·福克纳曾经说过的：“过去从未死亡，它甚至还没有过去。”在哈佛大学，
Joseph Hendrick has studied how people who lived in previous centuries continue to shape our lives today. Joe Hendrick, welcome to Hidden Brain. That's great to be with you. Joe, I find myself checking the time constantly. I'm always running from one thing to the other. I sometimes feel like I live my life according to the dictates of my calendar.
约瑟夫·亨里奇一直在研究前几个世纪的人们是如何继续塑造我们今天的生活的。乔·亨里奇，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起。乔，我发现自己一直在看时间。我总是从一件事忙到另一件事。我有时觉得我的生活是按照日历的指令来安排的。
You've studied what life was like for people before mechanical clocks were invented. Paint me a picture of that world. Yeah, that was a world governed by sunrise and sunset, where there were still 12 hours in a day, but the length of those hours varied. There were seasonal rhythms that helped people organize farming, and it was just a very different world than the constant interest in time and saving time and getting more time and thinking of time as money. I'm imagining that given that people lived in different time zones and in different latitudes,
你研究过机械钟发明之前人们的生活是什么样的。请为我描绘一下那个世界。是的，那是一个由日出和日落支配的世界，一天里虽然也有12个小时，但这些小时的长短是变化的。季节性的节奏帮助人们组织农耕，那是一个与我们现在不断关注时间、节省时间、争取更多时间以及将时间视为金钱的世界完全不同的世界。我猜想，考虑到人们生活在不同的时区和不同的纬度，
people really started and ended their days at different times in different places of the world. Yeah, I mean, everything was organized around sunrise. And, of course, that varies if you're not along the equator. That changes throughout the year. There were no electric lights. Candles were expensive. so people had to adapt to the availability of light. And of course, everybody was farmers, or almost everyone,
人们在世界不同地方开始和结束一天的时间确实不同。是的，我的意思是，一切都是围绕日出组织的。当然，如果你不在赤道附近，这一点就会有所不同。它在一年中会发生变化。那时没有电灯，蜡烛很贵，所以人们必须适应光线的可用性。当然，每个人都是农民，或者几乎每个人都是，
so that meant that the seasons really mattered a lot. The weather mattered a lot, and you had to organize your work around those cycles. I understand the first mechanical clocks appeared around the 13th century. That's right. They began spreading in northern Italy, so places like Milan and Parma. But then they were very popular, so they rapidly began spreading amongst urbanizing parts of Europe,
所以这意味着季节确实非常重要。天气非常重要，你必须围绕这些周期来组织你的工作。据我了解，第一批机械钟出现在13世纪左右。没错。它们开始在意大利北部传播，比如米兰和帕尔马等地。但后来它们非常受欢迎，所以迅速开始在欧洲城市化地区传播，
So getting to Paris and London. And initially there wasn't a clock per se. It was just tied to bells. So the cities and towns, everybody was with an earshot of the ringing bells. And so it would ring the beginning of the day and breakfast and lunch and whatnot. So the entire city would move in clockwork with the ringing bells. And then eventually you get a clock face and things go from there. I understand that various towns began to compete with one another to install a beautiful and magnificent.
比如传到了巴黎和伦敦。起初并没有所谓的时钟，它只是与钟声联系在一起。所以城市和城镇里的每个人都在钟声的听力范围内。它会敲响一天的开始、早餐、午餐等等。因此，整个城市都会随着钟声的节奏运转。最终出现了钟面，事情就从那里发展开了。据我了解，各个城镇开始竞相安装美丽而宏伟的
and clocks? That's right. So clocks were a sign of town wealth and prestige. Famous artisans would construct the clocks and clockmakers became an important occupation. And they wanted clocks that were as good as the clock in Vienna or the clock in Paris, you know, competing. I'm wondering how this invention changed the way people lived. So now all of a sudden, you know, you're not just going according to the rhythms and cycles of the sun. You actually have something that tells you it's 11 o'clock in the morning or 10 o'clock in the morning or two o'clock in the afternoon. How did that change day-to-day life? Yeah, it really changed the economic and political system. So legislatures would begin meeting at certain times of the day and there were fines if you were late. Contracts began to have exact
时钟？没错。所以时钟是城镇财富和声望的象征。著名的工匠会建造这些时钟，钟表匠成为了一种重要的职业。他们想要像维也纳或巴黎的时钟那样好的时钟，你知道，这是一种竞争。我想知道这项发明是如何改变人们的生活方式的。所以现在突然之间，你知道，你不仅仅是按照太阳的节奏和周期行事。你实际上有了一个告诉你现在是上午11点、上午10点或下午2点的东西。这如何改变了日常生活？是的，它确实改变了经济和政治体系。立法机构开始在一天中的特定时间开会，如果你迟到了会有罚款。合同开始有确切的
dates when you had to have things due. Witnesses were told to report at court at a certain hour. So it really just reorganized the society. Not only that, it was seen as a good and orderly life to live by the clock and have regular prayers and regular religious services and show up to work on time. So punctuality began to be tied to probity and all this was woven in with religion. So of course, monks had long been timing their prayers using candles and hourglasses and then they began to incorporate the clocks and the bells. I understand that there's fascinating research looking at towns and cities that, that install clocks before other towns and cities,
截止日期。证人被要求在特定时间向法院报告。所以它确实重组了社会。不仅如此，按时钟生活、有规律地祈祷和进行宗教仪式、准时上班被视为一种美好而有序的生活。因此，守时开始与正直联系在一起，而这一切都与宗教交织在一起。当然，僧侣们早就开始用蜡烛和沙漏来计时祈祷，然后他们开始引入时钟和钟声。据我了解，有一些引人入胜的研究观察了那些比其他城镇更早安装时钟的城镇和城市，
and that this had a profound effect on productivity and wealth? Yeah, so this is a fascinating research coming out of economics. And if you look at the few centuries after these towns throughout Europe adopt a clock, you actually see an uptick in economic growth in the centuries after the clock arrives. So it's not an instantaneous effect because people actually have to adapt their thinking. And it takes a long time to get used to thinking in this time-thrift way in which we all, you know, we're all very tied to the clock and we've internalized it. But that's not something that automatically happens. And do you think this increase in productivity, this increase in wealth was really a result of people harmonizing their schedules?
这是否对生产力和财富产生了深远的影响？是的，这是来自经济学的一项引人入胜的研究。如果你观察欧洲这些城镇采用时钟后的几个世纪，你会发现时钟出现后的几个世纪里经济增长确实有所上升。所以这不是一种即时的效果，因为人们实际上必须调整他们的思维。习惯这种我们大家都非常依赖时钟并将其内化的“时间节约”方式需要很长时间。但这并不是自动发生的事情。你认为这种生产力的提高、财富的增加，真的是人们协调时间表的结果吗？
In other words, I can show up somewhere and I know that someone's going to meet me at a certain time and place. I don't have to wait two hours for them to show up because, in fact, they're following some different cycle. Yeah, so it increased people's ability to coordinate. But it also began to affect other things like payment schedules. So once you have clocks, you can pay people by the hour. And then at the same time, you get the spreading of piece rates. So people begin manufacturing. Markets are spreading across these towns.
换句话说，我可以出现在某个地方，我知道有人会在特定的时间和地点与我见面。我不必等他们两个小时才出现，因为事实上，他们遵循的是某种不同的周期。是的，它提高了人们的协调能力。但它也开始影响其他事情，比如支付时间表。一旦有了时钟，你就可以按小时支付工资。与此同时，计件工资制也开始传播。所以人们开始从事制造业。市场在这些城镇中蔓延。
And then if you pay a piece rate, so per horseshoe that you're making, then people begin to think about. And if they have a clock, they can figure out, well, how many horseshoes can I make in an hour? Maybe I can make five. Well, what if I can make six? You know, then you'd be in to think about the world like that. So you're an anthropologist, Joe. I understand that you were once working in Fiji, and you noticed that the way that you think of time
如果你支付计件工资，比如你制造的每个马蹄铁，那么人们就开始思考。如果他们有钟，他们就能算出，嗯，我一小时能做多少个马蹄铁？也许我能做五个。嗯，如果我能做六个呢？你知道，然后你就会开始那样思考世界。乔，你是一位人类学家。据我了解，你曾经在斐济工作，你注意到你思考时间的方式
was very different from your collaborators in Fiji. Yeah, so I was starting a project, and I was hiring some students from the University of the South Pacific, excellent research assistants. We're assisting me in this village, and we were doing interviews and observations on daily life. We were doing some behavioral experiments, all kinds of different things.
与你在斐济的合作者非常不同。是的，当时我正在启动一个项目，我雇佣了一些南太平洋大学的学生，他们是非常出色的研究助理。他们在那个村庄协助我，我们正在进行访谈和日常生活观察。我们做了一些行为实验，各种各样的不同事情。
So I was kind of running the project in this, I was accustomed to, which meant we had morning meetings and certain appointments, and I would give people a certain amount of time to finish things. And initially, I wasn't having much luck. Although the research assistants were excellent in many ways, they didn't seem to be very tied into the clock the way I was. And so then I bought everyone watches. So I figured, you know, maybe I can solve this with technology.
所以我当时是以我习惯的方式运行这个项目，这意味着我们有早会和特定的预约，我会给人们一定的时间来完成事情。起初，我并没有取得多大成功。虽然研究助理在许多方面都很出色，但他们似乎并不像我那样依赖时钟。于是我给每个人都买了手表。我想，你知道，也许我可以用技术来解决这个问题。
And of course, I was paying everyone. This still didn't seem to change anything at all. Everybody was wearing the watches. And then on one funny occasion, I was working closely. We were looking at this laptop with a research assistant. And I happened to look down at his watch, and it said something like 1120. And it turned out his watch was about 25 minutes off. And so I think it had been that way for weeks or possibly longer.
当然，我当时在给每个人发工资。但这似乎仍然没有任何改变。每个人都戴着手表。然后在一个有趣的场合，我正在密切工作。我们正和一个研究助理看着这台笔记本电脑。我碰巧低头看了看他的手表，上面显示的时间大约是11点20分。结果发现他的手表慢了大约25分钟。我想它可能已经那样好几周甚至更久了。
So what's striking, of course, is that people like me certainly sort of bemoan the fact that other people are not punctual or they don't show up. But in some ways, you know, not paying attention to the clock is actually a more natural state of things, if you will. Yeah, that's right. In lots of places, it's considered bad to be paying too much attention to the time. When you meet with somebody, you shouldn't be rushing off to your next thing. You should be taking time to connect with them, see how their family is, swap stories, you know, sort of reconnect, focusing on the social. I mean, you know, in some societies, the clock is seen as the kind of the devil, right? Because it's what drives people away from
当然，引人注目的是，像我这样的人当然会抱怨别人不守时或者他们不出现。但在某种程度上，你知道，不关注时钟实际上是一个更自然的状态，如果你愿意这么说的话。是的，没错。在很多地方，过度关注时间被认为是坏事。当你和某人见面时，你不应该急着去忙下一件事。你应该花时间与他们建立联系，看看他们的家庭情况，交换故事，你知道，重新连接，专注于社交。我的意思是，你知道，在某些社会中，时钟被视为一种魔鬼，对吧？因为它驱使人们远离
really forming these tight social bonds and nurturing the social bonds through time. Psychologists, Arnor and Zion and colleagues have actually gone around the world and tried to measure this in different cities. And they found that things like how long it takes to get to a stamp, the rate at which the guy behind the counter is moving actually varies from city to city. And they actually correlated with the measures of individualism for those cities. meaning that places with higher individualism are more punctual and vice versa? That's right. And the person behind the counter is actually moving faster, and the clocks in public places are more accurate
真正形成这些紧密的社会纽带，并通过时间来培养这些社会纽带。心理学家阿诺·诺伦扎扬（Arnor and Zion）和同事们实际上走遍了世界，试图在不同的城市测量这一点。他们发现，比如去买邮票需要多长时间、柜台后面的人移动的速度，实际上因城市而异。他们实际上将其与这些城市的个人主义衡量标准联系起来。这意味着个人主义程度越高的城市越守时，反之亦然？没错。柜台后面的人实际上移动得更快，公共场所的时钟也更准确，
so that you can measure the accuracy of the clocks in public places. What's fascinating here is that these conceptions of time have seeped into our lives to the point that we're not thinking about them anymore. It's hard to imagine a time when people didn't keep track of time. Yeah, and it really... He structures our life. One of the amazing things, and you can find this in the work of Ben Franklin, is that he emphasizes the equation between time and money, which is not something you find elsewhere. And of course, this metaphor has now spread globally.
这样你就可以测量公共场所时钟的准确性。这里引人入胜的是，这些时间观念已经渗透到我们的生活中，以至于我们不再去思考它们了。很难想象一个人们不记录时间的时代。是的，它确实……它构建了我们的生活。令人惊奇的事情之一，你可以在本杰明·富兰克林的著作中找到，是他强调了时间和金钱之间的等式，这在其他地方是找不到的。当然，这个隐喻现在已经在全球范围内传播开来。
And this is one of the things that dominates our life. You know, we're always wasting time, saving time, losing time. You know, time is this currency that we're trying to get more of. We like to think our choices, our thoughts, and our habits are entirely our own. But in reality, our individual choices are often echoes of centuries of cultural evolution. When we come back, the role of history in shaping our behavior, thoughts, and feelings. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这是支配我们生活的事情之一。你知道，我们总是浪费时间、节省时间、失去时间。你知道，时间是我们试图获得更多的一种货币。我们喜欢认为我们的选择、思想和习惯完全是我们自己的。但实际上，我们的个人选择往往是几个世纪文化演变的共鸣。回来后，我们将探讨历史在塑造我们的行为、思想和感受方面的作用。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
We think that the lives we lead are shaped by the choices we make. But many of the routines we follow were shaped by centuries of history and cultural evolution. Anthropologist Joseph Hendrick looks at the way history and cultural evolution shape what we think, how we see the world, and the decisions we make. He's found that even things we see today as moral and right were often inventions by ancient actors who had specific goals and political aims in mind. I want to talk about the relationships that undergird most of our lives today, Joe. Marriage, the nuclear family, rules of inheritance.
我们认为我们所过的生活是由我们做出的选择所塑造的。但我们遵循的许多常规都是由几个世纪的历史和文化演变所塑造的。人类学家约瑟夫·亨里奇研究了历史和文化演变如何塑造我们的思维、我们看待世界的方式以及我们做出的决定。他发现，即使是我们今天视为道德和正确的事情，也往往是那些怀有特定目标和政治意图的古代行动者的发明。乔，我想谈谈今天支撑我们大多数人生活的关系。婚姻、核心家庭、继承规则。
Transport me back to pre-Christian Europe. What were familiar relationships like for most people back then? Well, at that point in European history, the kinship systems, the families, the clans look like large extended families. In Europe, there's patrilineal in lots of other places in the world. It's matrilineal. People inherit through the family by custom. Their societies are organized by clans. The economic system, the political system is all very tied into these kin relationships.
带我回到前基督教时代的欧洲。那时大多数人的家庭关系是什么样的？嗯，在欧洲历史的那一刻，亲属关系系统、家庭、氏族看起来就像大型的大家庭。在欧洲，有父系制度，在世界其他许多地方，则是母系制度。人们按照习俗通过家庭继承。他们的社会由氏族组织。经济体系、政治体系都与这些亲属关系紧密相连。
So, for example, many kin groups have corporate responsibility, which means if someone else in your clan, or including especially your brother, commits a crime, then you can be held responsible. So you're considered synonymous with your close kin. If someone within your kin group does something shameful, then it actually brings shame on you. So shame is contagious through these kin networks. Marriages are often arranged. People play bride price or dowry. This forms a bond between groups. And people are also tending to marry endogamously.
例如，许多亲属群体有集体责任，这意味着如果你的氏族中的某个人，包括特别是你的兄弟，犯了罪，那么你也要承担责任。所以你被认为与你的近亲是同义的。如果你的亲属群体中的某个人做了丢脸的事，那么它实际上会给你带来耻辱。所以耻辱是通过这些亲属网络传染的。婚姻通常是包办的。人们支付彩礼或嫁妆。这在群体之间形成了纽带。人们也倾向于近亲通婚。
So with close kin, like cousins, things like that, or other relatives. And kin also provided a kind of social security. They provided a kind of protection, insurance. I mean, so you had these large groups in some ways, and they were all responsible for each other, looking out for each other. That's right. So they're not only the core of the economic system, but they provided a social safety net.
所以与近亲，比如堂表亲之类，或其他亲戚。亲属也提供了一种社会保障。他们提供了一种保护、保险。我的意思是，你拥有这些大型群体，在某种程度上，他们都对彼此负责，互相照顾。没错。所以他们不仅是经济体系的核心，而且还提供了一个社会安全网。
So if your husband dies, a typical thing would be you would marry his brother. And then you would maintain the bond. And as a woman, you would be taken care of, and your children would still be part of that kin group. So there was all these social norms to kind of take care of things. If both parents were killed, then the children would automatically go to other members of the family, where they'd be raised and taken care of and whatnot. So at one point, the Roman Catholic Church begins to spread across Europe. Pope Gregory dispatches a mission with specific instructions regarding marriage in particular?
所以如果你的丈夫去世了，典型的情况是你可能会嫁给他的兄弟。然后你就会维持这种纽带。作为一名女性，你会得到照顾，你的孩子仍然是那个亲属群体的一部分。所以有所有这些社会规范来照顾事情。如果父母双亡，那么孩子会自动去到家庭的其他成员那里，在那里他们会被抚养和照顾等等。那么在某个时候，罗马天主教会开始在欧洲传播。教皇格列高利派遣了一个传教团，对婚姻有特别的指示？
Yeah, this is happening all throughout Europe as missionaries are moving from the Roman Empire and from Rome out to the Celtic tribes and other Anglo-Saxon tribes, other Germanic tribes, to try to spread Christianity to these places. And when this monk named Augustine arrives in Kent, he begins to convert the king and his wife, who was already, Christian, she married in, she was a Frankish princess. So Augustine queried the Pope to find out what kinds of things he should be conveying as he faces these challenges from the local people in Kent. And so one question he asked the Pope is, how distant must a relative be for a Christian marriage to be permissible? So can I marry second cousins? Can I marry third cousins? Another question was, can a man marry his stepmother or his brother's wife? And then can two brothers marry two sisters and can a man receive communion after a sex dream.
是的，这发生在整个欧洲，因为传教士正从罗马帝国和罗马出发，前往凯尔特部落和其他盎格鲁-撒克逊部落、其他日耳曼部落，试图将基督教传播到这些地方。当这个名叫奥古斯丁的僧侣到达肯特时，他开始皈依国王和他的妻子，她已经是基督徒了，她是嫁过来的，是一位法兰克公主。所以奥古斯丁询问教皇，想知道当他面对肯特当地人的这些挑战时，他应该传达什么样的事情。所以他问教皇的一个问题是，基督教婚姻允许的亲属关系必须有多远？所以我可以娶堂表亲吗？我可以娶表亲吗？另一个问题是，男人可以娶他的继母或他兄弟的妻子吗？然后两个兄弟可以娶两个姐妹吗？男人在做春梦后可以领圣餐吗？
How did the Pope respond to these questions? Yeah, so the Pope, to the first question, he said, definitely can't marry first cousins. During this period in history, the church was definitely banning first cousins. They would go on to ban all the way out to six cousins, but at this point, you could marry your second cousins, and you cannot marry your stepmother. So it's not about genetic relatedness. It's about these family relationships that are created. and certainly not your brother's wife.
教皇是如何回答这些问题的？是的，对于第一个问题，他说，绝对不能娶堂表亲。在这一历史时期，教会绝对是禁止堂表亲结婚的。他们后来甚至禁止到六代以内的表亲，但在这一点上，你可以娶你的表亲，而且你不能娶你的继母。所以这与遗传关系无关。这是关于所创造的这些家庭关系。当然也不能娶你兄弟的妻子。
So that would be a kind of leverett marriage. And the church banned that pretty early on in the history of the Catholic Church. Two brothers can marry two sisters, so that was okay. So another people commission arrives in England a couple of centuries later. They're checking in on the progress of Christianizing the Anglo-Saxons. What is it fine? Yes, and in general, there's a lot of progress on people officially accepting Christianity. lots of people have been baptized, but there's still problems around what they describe as incest,
那将是一种收继婚。教会很早就禁止了这一点。两个兄弟可以娶两个姐妹，所以那是可以的。那么几个世纪后，另一个教皇使团到达了英国。他们正在检查基督教化盎格鲁-撒克逊人的进展。他们发现了什么？是的，总的来说，人们在正式接受基督教方面取得了很大进展。许多人已经受洗，但围绕他们所描述的“乱伦”仍然存在问题，
by which they mean cousin marriage of various kinds, and also polygyny. So elite men are taking one primary wife, but they're also marrying other women as secondary wives and concubines. And so I'm imagining the church might not look kindly on these developments. Yeah, so the question was, is how do we put an end to this? You know, we like the idea that the church is spreading and these people are becoming Christians, but these forms of family weren't acceptable. So one of the things that the Christians really pushed, the church leadership really pushed,
他们指的是各种各样的表亲婚姻，还有一夫多妻制。所以精英男性在娶一位主要妻子的同时，也娶其他女性作为次要妻子和妾。所以我猜想教会可能不会对这些发展有好感。是的，所以问题是，我们如何结束这一切？你知道，我们喜欢教会正在传播、这些人正在成为基督徒的想法，但这些家庭形式是不可接受的。所以基督徒真正推动的事情之一，教会领导层真正推动的事情，
was the notion of illegitimate children. So the lever they used was that unless you were married in an official Christian church, then you're an illegitimate child, which meant secondary wives in this system, like in many places around the world, their children still had some inheritance rights, they were still recognized by the community,
是私生子的概念。所以他们使用的杠杆是，除非你在正式的基督教会结婚，否则你就是私生子，这意味着在这个系统中的次要妻子，就像世界上的许多地方一样，她们的孩子仍然拥有一些继承权，他们仍然被社区所认可，
But the church tries to put an end to that to prevent not only inheritance of wealth, but succession. And this is going to affect the royalty a lot because it means the church controls who gets to be the next leader when you have dissent of power down the bloodline. One of the other things that the church required was to ask newly married couples to set up independent households. Talk about this idea, Joe. Yeah, that's right. So that's called neolocal residence. And it's very rare in a global and historical perspective. So when young couples will marry, typically they would live either with the groom's family or the bride's family, depending on whether they're patrilocal or matrilocal. So that's the anthropological terminology. But what we find in Europe during this period is the church are encouraging them to marry later and set up an independent residence so that they're independent from either side of the family. And so you have a new couple making their own decisions independent of the family.
但教会试图结束这一点，不仅是为了防止财富的继承，也是为了防止权力的继承。这将对皇室产生很大影响，因为它意味着教会控制着当你有血缘权力传承时，谁能成为下一任领导人。教会要求的另一件事是要求新婚夫妇建立独立的家庭。谈谈这个想法，乔。是的，没错。这被称为新居制（neolocal residence）。在全球和历史的角度来看，这是非常罕见的。所以当年轻夫妇结婚时，通常他们会住在新郎家或新娘家，取决于他们是父系居住还是母系居住。这是人类学的术语。但我们在这一时期的欧洲发现的是，教会鼓励他们晚婚并建立独立的住所，这样他们就独立于家庭的任何一方。所以你有一对新夫妇在家庭之外做出自己的决定。
Now, I imagine that there must have been some people who looked at these new rules and said, you know, the hell were these rules, I'm just going to go my own way and do my own thing. Were there punishments for people who violated these rules? Yeah, there could be quite severe punishment. So the church can always excommunicate you. And then there's something even more severe called an anathema. And excommunication might, in the modern context, not sound very severe. But it meant you couldn't enter into contracts with other Christians. You were ostracized.
现在，我想一定有一些人看了这些新规则后说，见鬼去吧，这些规则是什么，我只想走自己的路，做自己的事。对于违反这些规则的人有惩罚吗？是的，可能会有相当严厉的惩罚。所以教会总是可以把你逐出教会。然后还有一种更严厉的东西叫做“绝罚”（anathema）。在现代语境下，逐出教会听起来可能并不严重。但这意味着你不能与其他基督徒签订合同。你被排斥了。
Those who might associate with an excommunicated individual got some of this spiritual taint on them, and it could affect their relationships. And in some cases, the church's protection of you was withdrawn. So if someone killed you or injured you, it wasn't considered a crime. So being excommunicated had real heft. Did all this change the way people behaved you? It took a long time, but it eventually. breaks European families in different parts of Europe to differing degrees down into monogamous nuclear families. So you went from large clans and kindreds down to, you know, the husband,
那些可能与被逐出教会的人交往的人会受到某种精神上的玷污，这可能会影响他们的关系。在某些情况下，教会对你的保护被撤回了。所以如果有人杀了你或伤害了你，那不被视为犯罪。所以被逐出教会确实有真正的分量。这一切改变了人们的行为方式吗？这花了很多时间，但最终它在欧洲不同地区以不同程度将欧洲家庭分解为一夫一妻制的核心家庭。所以你从大型氏族和亲属群体变成了，你知道，丈夫、
wife, and the children. And that was the basic family unit. One of the things that happened as a byproduct of this is that people started to think in terms of individual rights and personal responsibility rather than always prioritizing family loyalty and kin. Talk about this. I find this fascinating, Joe. Yeah, because what the church did by having these prohibitions and prescriptions about marriage and the family is you no longer had a big clan or this large extended family that you could rely on. You couldn't build alliances by marriage very easily. So people began to set up voluntary associations where people would join. These were often Christian-based.
妻子和孩子。这就是基本的家庭单位。作为这一过程的副产品，发生的事情之一是人们开始从个人权利和个人责任的角度思考，而不是总是优先考虑家庭忠诚和亲属关系。谈谈这个。我觉得这很迷人，乔。是的，因为教会通过对婚姻和家庭的这些禁令和规定所做的事情，是你不再拥有一个可以依赖的大氏族或大家庭。你不能轻易通过婚姻建立联盟。所以人们开始建立人们会加入的志愿协会。这些通常是基于基督教的。
You'd have to take an oath. And in order to get those organizations interested in you, you'd have to have certain attributes and accomplishments and things you brought to the table. So rather than having a large number of relationships that you inherited by birth and had via all these various kin ties, you had more of these optional relationships where you had, it was kind of a more of a marketplace for relationships. So this affected finding mates. So rather than arranged marriages, you had to find your own mates, friends, business partners, all these sorts of things. And it led to the proliferation of these voluntary associations. You talked earlier about how kin groups would look after one another. So if someone was in trouble or if someone lost a spouse or if children lost their parents, the kin, the larger kin would look after the person who needed help. What happened to those systems as things became more individualized?
你必须宣誓。为了让这些组织对你感兴趣，你必须具备某些属性、成就和你带来的东西。所以与其拥有大量通过出生继承并拥有所有这些各种亲属关系的亲属，你拥有更多这些可选的关系，这更像是一个关系的市场。所以这影响了寻找伴侣。所以与其包办婚姻，你必须找到自己的伴侣、朋友、商业伙伴，所有这些事情。它导致了这些志愿协会的激增。你之前谈到亲属群体如何互相照顾。所以如果有人遇到麻烦，或者如果有人失去了配偶，或者如果孩子失去了父母，亲属，更大的亲属会照顾需要帮助的人。当事情变得更加个人化时，这些系统发生了什么？
Yeah, a few different things. So the one thing the church did, it had to step forward almost immediately on this, is to take care of orphans and widows. Because normally they were sort of just slotted right into the Kinsip system, and there were norms that took care of them. What the church did meant that there was really no one to care for orphans and widows. So the church began to take them in, and they became core members of the church in that sense. These voluntary associations that people would join were also mutual self-help groups.
是的，发生了几件不同的事情。所以教会所做的一件事，它几乎必须立即在这方面采取行动，就是照顾孤儿和寡妇。因为通常他们只是被直接安置在亲属系统中，并且有照顾他们的规范。教会所做的事情意味着真的没有人照顾孤儿和寡妇。所以教会开始收留他们，从这个意义上说，他们成为了教会的核心成员。人们会加入的这些志愿协会也是互助小组。
So you would all mutually agree to help each other out if you were injured or had a period of unemployment or in your old age and whatnot. And then eventually, after the beginning of Protestantism, when the church is not doing this in places like England, after Henry VIII gets rid of all the Catholic institutions, Queen Elizabeth initiates the poor laws of 1600. And this is beginning to lay an official secular social safety net under people who might need it.
所以你们都会共同同意，如果你受伤了，或者有失业期，或者在老年时等等，互相帮助。然后最终，在清教徒运动开始后，当教会不再在英国等地做这件事时，在亨利八世摆脱了所有天主教机构之后，伊丽莎白女王发起了1600年的《济贫法》。这开始在可能需要它的人下面建立一个官方的世俗社会安全网。
So in some ways, the picture that you're painting, of course, shows us how many of the institutions that we're familiar with today actually had a point of origin that, in fact, they arose as a result of choices made by specific actors and specific circumstances, and many of them had specific political and social goals. That's right, but a lot of it is also unintended consequences. So the church, of course, was doing this because they believe that this is how God wanted it. And so when plagues would hit, the church would explain the plague. as a consequence of there being too much incest, by which they meant too much cousin marriage.
所以从某种程度上说，你描绘的画面当然向我们展示了我们今天熟悉的许多机构实际上有一个起源点，事实上，它们是特定行动者和特定情况下做出的选择的结果，而且其中许多有特定的政治和社会目标。没错，但其中很多也是意想不到的后果。所以教会当然这样做是因为他们相信这就是上帝想要的。所以当瘟疫来袭时，教会会解释瘟疫。作为乱伦过多的后果，他们指的是表亲婚姻过多。
And the breakdown of these families into monogamous nuclear families inadvertently led to the rise of these voluntary associations, which gave us the many charter towns of Europe, universities, new kinds of monasteries, and these mutual self-help associations, which eventually become occupational guilds. So many of those things become some of the core institutions of Western society. Talk about the family, the kind of family that we are used to seeing around these days, the nuclear family, you know, husband, wife, kids living by themselves. Talk about how that's actually quite unusual in the history of the species on the planet. Yeah, so when you look at the anthropological data on this, so anthropologists have put together something called the ethnographic Atlas, which is over 1,200 diverse societies that have been studied in ethnographic detail. You find that most 85% of societies allow elite and high status men to marry additional wives. You find cousin marriage in most societies is permitted. Neolocal residence is very rare, although common in the West, as we discussed.
这些家庭分解为一夫一妻制的核心家庭无意中导致了这些志愿协会的兴起，这给了我们欧洲的许多特许城镇、大学、新型修道院和这些互助协会，它们最终成为了职业行会。所以其中许多事情成为了西方社会的核心机构。谈谈家庭，我们这些天习惯看到的家庭类型，核心家庭，你知道，丈夫、妻子、孩子自己住。谈谈这在地球物种历史上实际上是多么不寻常。是的，所以当你查看关于这个的人类学数据时，人类学家整理了一个叫做“民族志图集”（Ethnographic Atlas）的东西，这是超过1200个在民族志细节上被研究过的多样化社会。你发现大多数85%的社会允许精英和高地位男性娶额外的妻子。你发现大多数社会允许表亲婚姻。新居制非常罕见，尽管在西方很常见，正如我们讨论的那样。
And just many other kinship practices like levered marriage, which you don't find in the West, are common around the world. So it's as if these norms evolved to build these dense networks of kin to organize production and consumption and distribution. And by preventing this from happening in parts of Western Europe, the church actually opened the door to new kinds of institutions and new ways of thinking about the world. You coined a term for the kind of modern psychology that animates Western, educated, industrialized, rich, and democratic societies. Tell me about this term, Joe. Yeah, so this began in about 2005 when I arrived at the University of British Columbia. And there I was moving out of anthropology into psychology, and I encountered two colleagues, Steve Hina and R. and Norenzion. And we would go to lunch together, and we were each talking about our research, and we were studying all studying cultural differences.
还有许多其他亲属实践，比如收继婚，你在西方找不到，但在世界各地都很常见。所以这就像这些规范进化是为了建立这些密集的亲属网络来组织生产、消费和分配。通过防止这种情况在西欧部分地区发生，教会实际上为新型机构和看待世界的新方式打开了大门。你为那种激励西方、受过教育、工业化、富裕和民主社会的现代心理学创造了一个术语。告诉我这个术语，乔。是的，这始于2005年左右，当时我到达不列颠哥伦比亚大学。在那里，我从人类学转向心理学，我遇到了两位同事，史蒂夫·海纳（Steve Hina）和阿诺·诺伦扎扬（R. and Norenzion）。我们会一起吃午饭，我们每个人都在谈论我们的研究，我们都在研究文化差异。
And what we had each independently found is that not only was there interesting cultural variation around the world, but that the populations most studied by psychologists and economists were psychologically peculiar when placed in a global and historical perspective. So we, you know, we began to think about and try to put together a case trying to convince psychologists and economists that they needed to think more broadly about psychological variation and just not generalized to all of humans based on one common culture that they most commonly studied. So we coined this acronym, or I guess it's a backronym, weird. It stands for Western educated, industrialized, rich, and democratic. You notice differences between these so-called weird societies and other types of cultures while you were working with a tribe in the Peruvian Amazon. Tell me about this work and what you found. Yeah, so this was my very first anthropological field work and I went to the Peruvian Amazon. I flew in on missionary planes and landed on the river and went into the village and then I traveled around in a dugout canoe around to the different villages. And at this point in my career, this is kind of the mid-1990s now, studying cooperation.
我们每个人独立发现的是，不仅世界各地存在有趣的文化差异，而且心理学家和经济学家研究最多的群体在从全球和历史角度来看时，在心理上是奇特的。所以我们，你知道，我们开始思考并试图整理出一个案例，试图说服心理学家和经济学家，他们需要更广泛地思考心理差异，而不是仅仅基于他们最常研究的一种共同文化来概括所有人。所以我们创造了这个首字母缩写，或者我想这是一个反向首字母缩写，WEIRD。它代表西方（Western）、受过教育（Educated）、工业化（Industrialized）、富裕（Rich）和民主（Democratic）。你在秘鲁亚马逊地区与一个部落工作时，注意到了这些所谓的WEIRD社会与其他类型的文化之间的差异。告诉我这项工作以及你发现了什么。是的，这是我第一次人类学田野调查，我去了秘鲁亚马逊地区。我乘坐传教士飞机飞入，降落在河上，进入村庄，然后我乘坐独木舟在不同的村庄之间穿梭。在我的职业生涯的这一点上，这大约是90年代中期，研究合作。
And one of the ideas that we were thinking about was the possibility that the willingness of other people to punish poor behavior, non-cooperative behavior, unfair behavior, might be part of the reason why humans are able to cooperate so much compared to other species. And so we were thinking about that. And then I heard about this experiment called the ultimatum game. And the ultimatum game is a simple bargaining game from economics in which two players are allotted a sum of money. And the first player can offer a portion of this money to the second player. The second player can either accept or reject. If they accept, both players get the amounts that were allocated. Or if they reject, then both players get zero.
我们正在思考的想法之一是，其他人惩罚不良行为、非合作行为、不公平行为的意愿，可能是人类能够比其他物种更好地合作的原因之一。所以我们正在思考这个问题。然后我听说了这个叫做“最后通牒博弈”（ultimatum game）的实验。最后通牒博弈是经济学中一个简单的讨价还价游戏，其中两个玩家被分配一笔钱。第一个玩家可以向第二个玩家提供这笔钱的一部分。第二个玩家可以接受或拒绝。如果他们接受，两个玩家都得到分配的金额。或者如果他们拒绝，那么两个玩家都得到零。
So for example, if the first player offers $10 out of the hundred to the second player and the second player accepts, they get 10. and the first player gets 90. If they reject, both players get zero. So when this had been done by economists in places like the U.S. and Zurich and elsewhere, they had found that most people offer 50-50 and that low offers are frequently rejected. That sort of fit my intuitions. So I thought that I could perform this experiment among the Machaganga, and they would show similar results, seemed intuitive, and that then this would be an interesting piece of the plaza.
例如，如果第一个玩家从一百美元中给第二个玩家10美元，而第二个玩家接受了，他们得到10美元，第一个玩家得到90美元。如果他们拒绝，两个玩家都得到零。所以当经济学家在美国、苏黎世和其他地方进行这项实验时，他们发现大多数人提供50-50，而且低报价经常被拒绝。这符合我的直觉。所以我认为我可以在马奇根加人（Machaganga）中进行这个实验，他们会表现出类似的结果，看起来很直观，然后这将是拼图的一个有趣部分。
puzzled in trying to explain human cooperation. But what I found was that they didn't feel inclined to reject at all, and people gave pretty low offers. So on average, people gave only 25% of the stake instead of 50%. And lots of people gave 15%. So this led to a big project, and we did this experiment in many different places, and we found a great deal of global variation. What do you think explains this?
在试图解释人类合作时感到困惑。但我发现他们根本没有拒绝的倾向，而且人们给出的报价相当低。所以平均而言，人们只给出了25%的份额而不是50%。很多人给出了15%。所以这导致了一个大项目，我们在许多不同的地方进行了这个实验，我们发现了大量的全球差异。你认为是什么解释了这一点？
What's happening in the minds of people in Peru that is different from Los Angeles? Well, I think it relates to a larger story that you and I discussed with the spread of the clocks. It has to do with market integration. And so what we found across these communities is that the more market integrated communities seem to have norms about fair dealing with anonymous others, with impersonal people you would just meet and not know their name or not know anything about their families. So more market integrated societies have norms that say you should just generally be fair-minded with people. people who you don't know and won't see again. Whereas the Machaganga lifestyle is a small-scale farming. They live scattered throughout the tropical forests of Peru, north of Cusco, where Machu Picchu is. And, you know, they're just not a lot of trade and exchange, so they don't have these market norms. And so to them, when I would interview them after, they would be like, yeah, why would anyone reject free money in this case, which is pretty close to the rational thing one might expect based on the game theory. Yeah. Right. The differences between these so-called weird cultures
秘鲁人们的思想中发生了什么与洛杉矶不同？嗯，我认为这与你和我讨论的关于时钟传播的更大故事有关。这与市场整合有关。所以我们在这些社区中发现的是，市场整合程度越高的社区似乎对与匿名他人、与你刚认识且不知道他们的名字或不知道他们家庭情况的非个人化的人进行公平交易有规范。所以市场整合程度越高的社会有规范，说你应该普遍对你不认识且以后不会再见到的人保持公平。而马奇根加人的生活方式是小规模农业。他们散居在秘鲁的热带森林中，在马丘比丘北部的库斯科。而且，你知道，没有太多的贸易和交换，所以他们没有这些市场规范。所以对他们来说，当我之后采访他们时，他们会说，是的，为什么在这种情况下有人会拒绝免费的钱，这非常接近基于博弈论人们可能预期的理性行为。是的。对。这些所谓的WEIRD文化之间的差异
and other cultures also show up in different psychological tests. Some research has been conducted looking at eye-tracking movements between Americans and East Stations. Tell me about this work. Yeah, so this is very interesting because it's perceptual. So psychologists have shown there's this tremendous variation in analytic versus holistic thinking. And one of the hallmarks that they found in terms of attention is what people pay attention to when they look at a scene or a picture or a video. And Americans, more analytically oriented societies, will tend to focus on the central object. So in this case, imagine that's an underwater scene with fish swimming around. The Americans tend to focus on the central fish, and they watch what the central fish does.
以及其他文化也会在不同的心理测试中表现出来。一些研究对美国人和东亚人的眼球追踪运动进行了观察。跟我谈谈这项工作吧。是的，这非常有趣，因为它是感知层面的。心理学家已经证明，在分析性思维与整体性思维之间存在巨大的差异。他们发现，注意力方面的一个标志性特征是人们在观察场景、图片或视频时关注的内容。美国人，即更倾向于分析的社会，往往会关注中心物体。在这种情况下，想象这是一个有鱼游来游去的水下场景。美国人倾向于关注中间的那条鱼，并观察它在做什么。
They don't tend to notice very much stuff in the background. The folks from East Asia would remember a lot more about, was going in the background, and their eyes would cover more of the scene and just not kind of glue to the central actor. Do you think this is, again, evidence of the propensity of weird societies to focus on individualism and individual objects? Yeah, so this is, this seems to be part of a larger package. You know, in an individualistic society, people tend to focus on themselves and their own
他们往往不太注意背景中的东西。来自东亚的人会记住更多关于背景中发生的事情，他们的眼睛会覆盖更多的场景，而不会仅仅盯着中心主体。你认为这是否再次证明了“怪异”（WEIRD）社会倾向于关注个人主义和个人物体的倾向？是的，这似乎是一个更大体系的一部分。你知道，在个人主义社会中，人们倾向于关注自己和自己的
attributes and they think about others dispositionally. So what are the attributes of another person, honest or dishonest, without thinking of all the contextual variation. Whereas if you're from a more holistic society, more collectivistic society, you're thinking about the relationships between individuals. People aren't either honest or dishonest. They're honest in some circumstances with some kinds of people and not so honest in other kinds of circumstances. So there's this interesting, different ways of thinking about the world. One of the things that I find fascinating about all of this is that it highlights just how much we can take culture for granted.
属性，并且他们倾向于从性格角度去思考他人。也就是说，另一个人的属性是什么，是诚实还是不诚实，而不去考虑所有的情境变化。然而，如果你来自一个更整体的社会，一个更集体主义的社会，你就会思考个体之间的关系。人们并非非诚实即不诚实。他们在某些情况下对某些人是诚实的，而在其他情况下则不那么诚实。所以，这是一种看待世界的有趣且不同的方式。关于这一切，我感到着迷的一点是，它突显了我们对文化是多么的习以为常。
So, for example, we might live in mostly monogamous societies, and so we assume that humans must be wired for monogamy. That, in fact, might not be the case. Yeah, it's amazing how strong the intuition is, is that however it is where I live is how it is to be human. So, yeah, one of the things I've been most interested over my career is trying to figure out what is actually pan-human and what is just the particular societies that we grow up in.
例如，我们可能生活在大多是一夫一妻制的社会中，因此我们认为人类一定是为一夫一妻制而生的。事实上，情况可能并非如此。是的，这种直觉非常强烈，即无论我生活的地方是什么样，人类就应该是那个样子的。所以，是的，我职业生涯中最感兴趣的事情之一就是试图弄清楚什么是真正全人类共有的，而什么仅仅是我们成长过程中所处的特定社会所特有的。
The invention of clerks and religious rules for marriage all profoundly influenced the way modern people think and behave. More about how culture shapes our minds when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Have you ever given thought to how your daily life might be shaped by events from the distant things? past or by traditions thousands of miles away?
文书工作和宗教婚姻规则的发明，深刻地影响了现代人的思维和行为方式。当我们回来时，将深入探讨文化如何塑造我们的思想。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你是否曾思考过，你的日常生活可能受到遥远过去事件或数千英里外传统的影响？
If you have a personal example you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience about how the past shapes your behavior today, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, culture. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Anthropologist Joseph Hendrick is the author of the books The Secret of Our Success,
如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人例子，关于过去如何塑造你今天的行为，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请使用“culture”。再说一遍，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。人类学家约瑟夫·亨里奇（Joseph Henrich）是《我们成功的秘密》一书的作者，
How Culture is Driving Human Evolution, Domesticating Our Species and Making Us Smarter, and The Weirdest People in the World, How the West Became Psychologically Peculiar and Particularly Prosperous. Joe, in June 1845, two ships set sail from Britain in search of the fabled Northwest Passage. Tell me about this mission and the man who was leading it. Yeah, so this mission was led by Sir John Franklin, and it was an effort to find the fabled Northwest Passage, with economic goals of energizing trade and connecting Europe and East Asia, and also doing some mapping of that area, understanding the magnetic field. And it was a fascinating expedition because it was kind of the Apollo mission of the 19th century. This was a super well-outfitted ship, had icebreaker technology.
《文化如何推动人类进化、驯化我们的物种并使我们更聪明》，以及《世界上最怪异的人：西方人如何变得心理独特且格外繁荣》。乔，1845年6月，两艘船从英国启航，寻找传说中的西北航道。跟我谈谈这次任务以及领导它的那个人。是的，这次任务由约翰·富兰克林爵士（Sir John Franklin）领导，旨在寻找传说中的西北航道，其经济目标是促进贸易并连接欧洲和东亚，同时也对该地区进行一些测绘，了解磁场。这是一次引人入胜的探险，因为它就像19世纪的阿波罗计划。这是一艘装备极其精良的船，拥有破冰技术。
It had retractable screw propellers. It was insulated with cork. There were desalinators on board. And it had a new technology canned food, which was meant to allow the crews to live for over a year trapped in the ice in the north. So they were ready to engage in this exploration. And they were led by this experienced guy, John Franklin. And so they headed out, and the very beginning of the trip went fine. They were exploring the islands north of Canada.
它有可伸缩的螺旋桨。它用软木塞隔热。船上有海水淡化装置。它还有一项新技术——罐头食品，旨在让船员在被困在北方的冰层中时能生存一年多。所以他们准备好进行这次探索了。他们由这位经验丰富的人约翰·富兰克林领导。于是他们出发了，旅程的最初阶段很顺利。他们正在探索加拿大北部的岛屿。
They wintered near an island called Devon Island. The ice came in around the ship as expected. You know, I guess they cracked open the canned food and waited the winter out until the ice retracted. And then they kept exploring. But the next year, they were near King William Island and they were exploring around there. And the ice came in again and froze them in. That was all expected. But the next summer, the ice didn't seem to retract.
他们在德文岛（Devon Island）附近过冬。正如预期的那样，冰层在船周围聚拢。你知道，我想他们打开了罐头食品，等待冬天过去，直到冰层消退。然后他们继续探索。但第二年，他们在威廉王岛（King William Island）附近，正在那里进行探索。冰层再次聚拢并将他们冻住。这一切都在预料之中。但第二年夏天，冰层似乎没有消退。
And so they were going to have to winter again, and that seemed like that was going to be a problem. Their leader Franklin promptly died. So the men were trapped in the ice, and they were faced with a challenge of living off the land, because they have to see if they can use their big brains and great intelligence to figure out how to do something very basic, which is surviving in the Arctic. What happened? Well, things did not go well. So the men eventually left the ship, and they began trying to start.
所以他们不得不再次过冬，这看起来会是个问题。他们的领导者富兰克林很快就去世了。于是，男人们被困在冰层中，面临着靠土地生存的挑战，因为他们必须看看能否利用他们的大脑和卓越的智慧来弄清楚如何做一件非常基本的事情，那就是在北极生存。发生了什么？嗯，事情进展得并不顺利。所以男人们最终离开了船，并开始尝试
survive on King Williams Island. They left some notes along the way, which were later found, and the ships have soon been found. So we're not exactly sure what happened, although we know from tales from the Inuit bands that they encountered, that there was probably some cannibalism going on. One Inuit story has them, first encountering them and beginning to exchange some meat, but then they realize the men are carrying frozen limbs. It turned out frozen limbs of their comrades probably. And then the men all just disappear and leave no trace of them other than the stories and the minds of the Inuit. It led to a big rescue expedition. So explorers from all around the world converged on the Canadian Arctic to try to find these guys.
在威廉王岛上生存。他们沿途留下了一些后来被发现的笔记，船只也很快被找到了。所以我们不确定到底发生了什么，尽管我们从他们遇到的因纽特人部落的故事中得知，可能发生了一些同类相食的情况。一个因纽特人的故事说，他们最初遇到这些人并开始交换一些肉，但后来他们意识到这些人带着冷冻的肢体。事实证明，那很可能是他们同伴的冷冻肢体。然后这些人就消失了，除了因纽特人脑海中的故事外，没有留下任何痕迹。这导致了一次大规模的救援行动。因此，来自世界各地的探险家聚集在加拿大北极地区，试图找到这些人。
Now, you pointed out something really interesting in passing here, which is that there were people who were living in this area, presumably successfully for a long period of time. Why couldn't these men survive? Yeah, it's amazing. The group the Nescalate that was living there, Inuit, there were for the island that Franklin was trapped on is land of fat. Because for them, it was a rich environment that they could live on and winter on the ice and hunt seals and in other seasons, shoot caribou with their bows. They could render seal blubber or seal fat into oil that they could use for lights, for illumination and heating. They could spear salmon during certain seasons. They made kayaks there. To them, there was just a lot of resources there. But to Franklin's men, you know, it was this barren expanse.
现在，你顺便指出了一个非常有趣的事情，那就是在这个地区有人居住，而且显然已经成功生活了很长一段时间。为什么这些人无法生存？是的，这太神奇了。住在那里的一群因纽特人，对于富兰克林被困的岛屿来说，那是“脂肪之地”。因为对他们来说，这是一个富饶的环境，他们可以在上面生活，在冰上过冬，捕猎海豹，在其他季节用弓箭射杀驯鹿。他们可以将海豹鲸脂或海豹脂肪提炼成油，用于照明和取暖。他们可以在特定季节捕捞鲑鱼。他们在那里制作皮划艇。对他们来说，那里有很多资源。但对富兰克林的人来说，你知道，那是一片荒凉的广阔地带。
And, you know, it seemed impossible to survive there. I understand that some years before this expedition, another crew had found themselves stranded in the same area. Tell me about this group and what happened to them. Yeah, that was led by an explorer named Ross. and I think it's a great example because we can compare the explorers that did well on King Williams Island with what happened to the Franklin expedition. And the main difference is in how they interacted with the Inuit. So the Ross Expedition begins to open up trade relationships with the Inuit. They're able to get all kinds of clothing and food.
而且，你知道，在那里生存似乎是不可能的。我了解到，在这次探险前几年，另一组船员发现自己被困在同一地区。跟我谈谈这群人以及他们发生了什么。是的，那是由一位名叫罗斯（Ross）的探险家领导的。我认为这是一个很好的例子，因为我们可以将威廉王岛上表现出色的探险家与富兰克林探险队发生的事情进行比较。主要的区别在于他们如何与因纽特人互动。所以罗斯探险队开始与因纽特人建立贸易关系。他们能够获得各种各样的衣服和食物。
And so they're just able to survive much more easily by taking advantage of the vast knowledge of the Inuit. they travel and explore through their new allies and new friends with the Inuit. You describe several things that the Inuit were able to teach the visitors, including fairly complex tasks involving hunting and trapping. Can you describe some of these for me just to show how intricate this knowledge system was? Yeah, I mean, the amount of insight and knowledge and skill that the Inuit have to survive in this environment is really incredible. So one thing that the Inuit routinely did during this period was they would be able to hunt seals. And so you had to figure out where the seals are
因此，他们能够通过利用因纽特人的丰富知识，更容易地生存下来。他们通过与因纽特人的新盟友和新朋友一起旅行和探索。你描述了因纽特人能够教给访客的几件事，包括涉及狩猎和诱捕的相当复杂的任务。你能为我描述其中一些，以展示这个知识体系是多么复杂吗？是的，我的意思是，因纽特人在这种环境中生存所具备的洞察力、知识和技能确实令人难以置信。所以因纽特人在这一时期经常做的一件事就是他们能够捕猎海豹。所以你必须弄清楚海豹会在哪里
going to be and it had to be an area that was covered with snow so you couldn't hear your feet. You had to create the hole in the ice. You had to know, or you would find the holes and you would see if they were actively used by seals. And then you would use a spear to wait there until you got a sense that the seal was there, and they had little feather markers that would tell you if the seal was there, and then you would plunge your harpoon into the hole. You needed a special bare-bone handle
出现，而且它必须是一个被雪覆盖的区域，这样你就听不到你的脚步声。你必须在冰上凿个洞。你必须知道，或者你会找到这些洞，看看它们是否被海豹积极使用。然后你会用长矛在那里等待，直到你感觉到海豹在那里，他们有小的羽毛标记，会告诉你海豹是否在那里，然后你会把鱼叉刺进洞里。你需要一个特殊的裸骨手柄
because you needed some really strong materials for the end of it. You would use to drive into the seal, and then, of course, you had to know what to do with the seal once you got it out. They also made sleds, and they made use of dogs, and they made this special cold weather clothing. So just an immense range of cultural knowledge.
因为你需要一些非常坚固的材料来制作它的末端。你会用它来刺入海豹，当然，一旦你把它弄出来，你必须知道如何处理海豹。他们还制作雪橇，利用狗，并制作这种特殊的防寒服装。所以这是一种极其广泛的文化知识。
And of course, this is not testament to the fact that the Inuit were necessarily smarter than their visitors. They'd had more time, and they'd passed on this knowledge, presumably from generation to generation, each generation adding some new insights. Yeah, so that's the key thing, is that the Nescalate benefited from this cumulative cultural evolution. So over generations, this large body of knowledge had increasingly adapted the Inuit to surviving in this environment. So it wasn't that they were smarter. It's that they had this large body of cumulative knowledge, which Franklin's men did not have. So this gets at something that researchers call the cultural intelligence hypothesis. What is this hypothesis, Joe?
当然，这并不证明因纽特人一定比他们的访客更聪明。他们有更多的时间，并且他们已经把这些知识一代又一代地传下去，每一代人都增加了一些新的见解。是的，这就是关键所在，因纽特人受益于这种累积的文化进化。所以经过几代人的积累，这些大量的知识已经使因纽特人越来越适应在这种环境中生存。所以并不是他们更聪明。而是他们拥有这种大量的累积知识，而富兰克林的人没有。所以这就触及了研究人员所说的“文化智力假说”。这个假说是什么，乔？
Well, this is the idea that really our brains have evolved and why they've gotten so much bigger than our primate relatives or than our ancestors two million years ago is that our brains evolved to acquire, store, and organize cultural information. So it's not that our brains have evolved to individually solve problems. What we're really good at is taking advantage of all the information stored in the minds around us and the minds of others. And then we acquire that. And we can even create new things by recombining things that we acquire from different people. So this kind of cultural transmission of knowledge and ideas leads to an idea that you call the collective brain. What do you mean by this, Joe?
嗯，这就是这个观点：我们的大脑之所以进化，以及为什么它们比我们的灵长类亲属或两百万年前的祖先大得多，是因为我们的大脑进化到可以获取、存储和组织文化信息。所以并不是我们的大脑进化到可以单独解决问题。我们真正擅长的是利用存储在我们周围的人和他人头脑中的所有信息。然后我们获取这些信息。我们甚至可以通过重新组合我们从不同人那里获取的东西来创造新事物。所以这种知识和思想的文化传播导致了一个你称之为“集体大脑”的概念。你这是什么意思，乔？
Well, the collective brain emerges when people are learning from each other because information is flowing around from different minds. And once you have this view, the ability of a society to generate innovation or creative ideas, this process of cumulative cultural evolution that we referred to before is going to depend on the size of the population, the social interconnectedness among individuals, because that allows the information to flow and the cognitive diversity in those minds. So you're actually going to get more creativity and more innovation out of a population when you have a larger population that's more interconnected and more cognitively diverse. And that's the collective brain. And you can see this in places like Silicon Valley, for example, where lots of people are interacting with each other, lots of people are learning from each other. And things are able to progress relatively quickly because people are building very rapidly on top of what other people have built. That's right. And you see this all over the place.
嗯，当人们互相学习时，集体大脑就会出现，因为信息在不同的头脑之间流动。一旦你有了这个观点，一个社会产生创新或创造性思想的能力，即我们之前提到的累积文化进化过程，将取决于人口规模、个体之间的社会互联性，因为这允许信息流动，以及这些头脑中的认知多样性。所以，当你拥有一个规模更大、互联性更强且认知更多样化的人口时，你实际上会从人口中获得更多的创造力和创新。这就是集体大脑。你可以在硅谷等地看到这一点，例如，那里有很多人在互动，很多人在互相学习。事情能够相对快速地取得进展，因为人们正在非常迅速地建立在其他人已经建立的基础上。没错。而且你在各地都能看到这一点。
So, for example, when railroads were spreading across the U.S. or in Sweden or in Germany, when a town got hooked into the larger collective brain, you begin to get more creative products coming from that town. Just the simple physical link. This touches on something that you call gene culture co-evolution. What does this mean? Well, one of the key elements of human history that is really emerging now is that a lot of the interesting aspects of our physiology, anatomy, and biology were actually dream. driven by selection pressures created by cultural evolution. So one of the best studied cases of gene culture co-evolution is the spread of fire, making a fire and cooking.
所以，例如，当铁路在美国、瑞典或德国蔓延时，当一个城镇与更大的集体大脑连接起来时，你就会开始从那个城镇获得更多的创造性产品。仅仅是简单的物理连接。这触及了你所说的“基因-文化共同进化”。这是什么意思？嗯，人类历史的一个关键要素现在正在显现，那就是我们生理、解剖和生物学的许多有趣方面实际上是
And so if you look at our anatomy and physiology, our digestive track, and you compare it to other species, our fellow apes and stuff, we seem to have stomachs that are too small, colones that are too small, we have these tiny teeth. but these actually make sense once you realize that we've long been a primate that cooks its food because cooking acts as a kind of predigestion, food processing more generally. And then this allowed natural selection to reduce the size of our stomachs, shrink our colones, give us these small teeth, because we do the digestion in this cultural way by taking advantage of fire and cooking. But of course, we don't innately know how to make fire or cook. So this is something that is completely culturally transmitted, but then has dramatically shaped our physiology and anatomy. Another example of how our genetic inheritance and cultural practices are intertwined has to do with the practice of monogamy and testosterone levels in men.
由文化进化所创造的选择压力驱动的。所以基因-文化共同进化的研究最好的案例之一就是火的传播、生火和烹饪。所以如果你看看我们的解剖结构和生理机能，我们的消化道，并将它与其他物种、我们的猿类同伴等进行比较，我们的胃似乎太小了，结肠太小了，我们有这些细小的牙齿。但一旦你意识到我们长期以来一直是一种烹饪食物的灵长类动物，这些就说得通了，因为烹饪起到了某种预消化的作用，更广泛地说是食物加工。然后这使得自然选择能够减小我们胃的大小，缩小我们的结肠，给我们这些细小的牙齿，因为我们通过利用火和烹饪，以这种文化方式进行消化。但当然，我们并不是天生就知道如何生火或烹饪。所以这是完全通过文化传播的东西，但随后极大地塑造了我们的生理和解剖结构。我们遗传基因和文化习俗如何交织在一起的另一个例子与一夫一妻制的习俗和男性的睾酮水平有关。
Tell me about this research, Joe. Yeah, so this is one of these things where the assumption that everybody was monogamous, people began to make generalizations. and one of the things that they generalized is that testosterone declines over men's lives. But then anthropologists began to study other societies and looking and comparing what happens to men's testosterone in polygynous versus monogamous societies. So the standard result from monogamous societies is that men testosterone declines after they marry and then it declines again after they have their first child. And this makes good sense in comparisons with other species because decline.
跟我谈谈这项研究，乔。是的，这是那种假设每个人都是一夫一妻制，人们开始进行概括的事情之一。他们概括的一件事是，男性的睾酮水平随着年龄的增长而下降。但随后人类学家开始研究其他社会，观察并比较男性睾酮在多配偶制社会与一夫一妻制社会中发生的情况。所以一夫一妻制社会的标准结果是，男性在结婚后睾酮水平下降，在有了第一个孩子后再次下降。与其他物种相比，这很有道理，因为下降。
and testosterone are associated with fatherhood in other species. You're beginning to engage in the nest. You've stopped your pursuit of mates and you're not engaging in much competition with other males at this point because you're moving into a fatherhood phase. But in polygynous societies, we don't see the decline, which fits the theory really well, but it just shows how institutions, whether you're going to have polygamy or inogamy, affects the endocrinology of human bodies. And so you need to think of cultural endocrinology. So the institutions affect the hormonal, life cycle patterns. So we've talked about all the ways in which history influences our culture, culture that influences not just our psychology, but also our biology. That feeds back into the whole cycle and can influence history again. Talk about sort of the role that this is playing and transforming our understanding of our minds and our societies. Because I think when most of us think about human psychology, you know, we tend to think of it
睾酮在其他物种中与父性有关。你开始参与筑巢。你已经停止了对配偶的追求，并且此时你没有与其他雄性进行太多竞争，因为你正在进入父亲阶段。但在多配偶制社会中，我们没有看到这种下降，这非常符合理论，但它只是表明制度，无论你是实行多配偶制还是一夫一妻制，都会影响人类身体的内分泌。所以你需要考虑文化内分泌学。因此，制度影响荷尔蒙、生命周期模式。所以我们已经谈到了历史影响我们文化的所有方式，这种文化不仅影响我们的心理，也影响我们的生物学。这反馈到整个循环中，并可能再次影响历史。谈谈这在改变我们对思想和社会的理解方面所起的作用。因为我认为当我们大多数人思考人类心理时，你知道，我们倾向于认为它
in terms of what's happening inside the individual brain, what's happening inside this one person's head. And really what your painting is a picture that is far, far larger. Yes, that's right. So in the picture that I'm painting, our institutions, our languages, feed back, and they shape our psychology. Now, of course, what we just talked about was gene culture co-evolution. So in the long run, they might affect our genetic evolution. But what's underappreciated is how much these things shape our psychology in the short term, because our minds have evolved through this gene culture co-evolutionary process to adapt developmentally as we're growing up in these different environments. So something like our cell phones, you know, are going to affect
是关于个体大脑内部发生的事情，关于这个人的头脑内部发生的事情。而你所描绘的实际上是一幅远大得多的图景。是的，没错。所以在我描绘的图景中，我们的制度、我们的语言，反馈并塑造了我们的心理。当然，我们刚才谈到的是基因-文化共同进化。所以从长远来看，它们可能会影响我们的基因进化。但被低估的是这些东西在短期内对我们心理的塑造程度，因为我们的思想已经通过这种基因-文化共同进化过程进化，以便在我们成长于这些不同环境时进行发育适应。所以像我们的手机，你知道，将会影响
things like our memory and our attention. So they're actually changing how things are processed in our minds. One of my favorite examples of this is, you know, for most of human history, people didn't read. It was really not until the 16th century that large segments of the population began to read. But when you learn to read as a child, it actually reshapes the wiring in your brain so that you get thicker corpus callosum. That's the information highway that connects the right and left hemispheres. You get specialized circuitry in your left ventral hemisphere. And you get more whole brain activation even when you hear spoken language.
诸如我们的记忆力和注意力之类的事情。所以它们实际上正在改变我们头脑中处理事物的方式。我最喜欢的例子之一是，你知道，在人类历史的大部分时间里，人们是不读书的。直到16世纪，很大一部分人口才开始阅读。但当你作为一个孩子学习阅读时，它实际上重塑了你大脑中的线路，使你拥有更厚的胼胝体。那是连接左右半球的信息高速公路。你在左侧腹侧半球获得了专门的电路。即使当你听到口语时，你也会获得更多的大脑整体激活。
So it doesn't just affect the reading. It actually affects how we process spoken language. So it's just a case where a cultural practice learning to read actually changes a bunch of things about our brains and about how we take in information. I'm wondering if this can also explain things like the Industrial Revolution, Joe. When you think about a sudden explosion of technological innovation, creativity, etc., do you think that's driven in part by this kind of cultural learning? Yeah, I really think that that is a core idea,
所以它不仅影响阅读。它实际上影响我们处理口语的方式。所以这只是一个文化习俗——学习阅读——实际上改变了我们大脑的许多方面以及我们接收信息方式的案例。我想知道这是否也能解释像工业革命这样的事情，乔。当你想到技术创新、创造力等的突然爆发时，你认为这在一定程度上是由这种文化学习驱动的吗？是的，我真的认为这是一个核心思想，
and I bring that out in the weirdest people in the world in my book. So when these monogamous nuclear families formed and these impersonal institutions be created, people were released from the bonds of their kinship. And we know from historical data that they began moving around Europe. And the nature of the institutions also changed. So monasteries became these transnational franchises. And artisans would have a journeyman phase in which they would go out to work with other masters
我在我的书《世界上最怪异的人》中提到了这一点。所以当这些一夫一妻制的核心家庭形成，这些非人格化的制度被创造出来时，人们从亲属关系的束缚中解放了出来。我们从历史数据中知道，他们开始在欧洲各地流动。制度的性质也发生了变化。所以修道院变成了这些跨国特许经营机构。工匠们会有一个熟练工阶段，在这个阶段他们会出去与其他大师一起工作
after they finished training with this. All this led to greater movement of ideas around Europe, which led to more rapid innovation. Urbanization, of course, you know, was rising during this whole period, for the same reason. Universities were one of the institutions, the voluntary associations that spread, and eventually Protestant gives rise to literacy. All of these things come together
在他们完成培训之后。所有这一切导致了思想在欧洲的更大范围流动，这导致了更快的创新。当然，城市化在整个时期都在上升，原因也是如此。大学是传播的志愿协会之一，最终新教产生了识字率。所有这些东西汇集在一起
to just create a much larger collective brain in Europe that eventually results in the industrial revolution and really gives birth to the modern world. Culture doesn't just make us smarter. It can also make us more vulnerable to sickness and to death. In our companion episode, exclusively for our subscribers to hear, Hidden Brain Plus, we look at how cultural beliefs can produce higher rates of illness,
在欧洲创造了一个大得多的集体大脑，最终导致了工业革命，并真正催生了现代世界。文化不仅使我们更聪明。它也可能使我们更容易受到疾病和死亡的影响。在我们为订阅者独家提供的配套剧集中，《隐藏的大脑Plus》，我们研究了文化信仰如何导致更高的疾病率、
homicide, and suicide. If you're already a subscriber, that episode is available to you right now in this podcast feed. It's titled, How Culture Can Harm You. If you're not yet a subscriber, please consider signing up. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain. You can get a free trial in both places.
他杀和自杀。如果你已经是订阅者，该剧集现在可以在此播客订阅源中收听。标题是《文化如何伤害你》。如果你还不是订阅者，请考虑注册。访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.com/hiddenbrain。你可以在这两个地方获得免费试用。
and you'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or Apple.co. .hiddenbrain. Joseph Hendrick is an anthropologist at Harvard University. He is the author of the weirdest people in the world, how the West became psychologically peculiar and particularly prosperous, and the secret of our success, how culture is driving human evolution,
你将立即获得我们所有订阅者专享内容的访问权限。再说一遍，地址是support.hiddenbrain.org或Apple.co/hiddenbrain。约瑟夫·亨里奇是哈佛大学的人类学家。他是《世界上最怪异的人：西方人如何变得心理独特且格外繁荣》以及《我们成功的秘密：文化如何推动人类进化、
domesticating our species, and making us smarter. smarter. Joseph Hendrick, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Well, it was great to be with you. Have you ever given thought to how your daily life might be shaped by events in the distant past or by traditions thousands of miles away? If you have a personal example you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience about how the past may be shaping your behavior today or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org.
驯化我们的物种并使我们更聪明》的作者。约瑟夫·亨里奇，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。嗯，很高兴能和你在一起。你是否曾思考过，你的日常生活可能受到遥远过去事件或数千英里外传统的影响？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人例子，关于过去如何塑造你今天的行为，或者关于本集的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, culture. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
邮件主题请使用“culture”。再说一遍，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。